How to Win Friends and Influence People
is the title of possibly the most famous
book of the 20th century it's also one
of the book's most routinely ridiculed
by people who think they're clever why
on Earth would an intelligent person
need help with something as basic as
that intellectuals have mocked down the
decades and in any case good people
don't need to win friends they already
have them and they don't need to
influence them they just need to say
important things
but these were not the assumptions of a
man far cleverer and more important than
intellectual history has ever been
prepared to allow
born in 1888 into a poor farming family
in rural Missouri Dale Carnegie left
school in his teens and rather than
attend University he spent his years
selling bacon and soap to people living
in isolated ranches he then got involved
in adult education and spent tens of
thousands of evenings giving talks to
small audiences in out of the way towns
with over prominent ears and a prosaic
haircut Dale Carnegie was almost the
anti-type of what we imagine a great and
centrally important writer might be like
in 1936 when he was in his late 40s he
summed up his views on being nice in a
book that was ridiculed by intellectuals
then and now how to win friends and
influence people
the issues that Carnegie addresses are
utterly basic we spend vast parts of our
lives trying to build relationships
hoping to get others to appreciate who
we are to understand us and grasp what
we have to offer them and yet our
efforts are very often far from
successful
Carnegie pinpointed things we
desperately need to know and get good at
but which have been largely neglected by
previous writers
what Carnegie suggests sounds entirely
like Common Sense smile remember
someone's name listen to them think
about what they want don't make your
success come at the price of theirs
don't tell others they're wrong get to
understand and appreciate why they think
as they do especially if it strikes you
as misguided and yet these are precisely
the things we generally forget to do
Carnegie recognized with astonishing
Clarity how naive sounding the advice we
need often really is our culture wants
us to imagine that what we need to know
a very complicated things a university
will make sure its science students
understand the theory of relativity or
that it's Humanities graduates are
acquainted with fouca's views on 19th
century prisons we're quite good at
abstruse things and yet we trip up on
issues that are diametrically opposite
in character that a simple emotional and
interpersonal they involve not
demonstrating how much we know but
rather showing how much we like other
people knowledge of the truth is a tiny
fraction of what it takes to make the
truth effective in the world what we
need in Spades is charm and an ability
to persuade others that we are on their
side
It's never enough to feel heartily
Superior or as unfortunately
pessimistically inferior and simply wait
for others to come to us we have to
master the art of winning people over to
our side and will be persuaded to change
our minds only by people that we like
and who we feel love and understand us
that is by people who've taken Dale
Carnegie's vital lessons to Heart